reacción en las calles la decisión
presidencial calles ayer el presidente
de la república de túnez destituyó este
domingo al primer ministro y suspendió
la actividad legislativa tras un día
marcado por protestas
antigubernamentales alrededor del país
la primera decisión es congelar todos
los poderes del parlamento la segunda
decisión es la de quitarle la inmunidad
a todos los miembros del parlamento la
tercera decisión es que el presidente
asuma la autoridad ejecutiva con la
ayuda de un gobierno liderado por un
primer ministro que será nombrado por el
presidente de la república el anuncio
del presidente fue una reacción al
descontento popular con el movimiento
enahda que constituía el principal apoyo
legislativo del primer ministro
destituido jean machi el grupo demócrata
islamista fue re legalizado en 2011 tras
la revuelta que derrocó al régimen de
ben alí una década después es el partido
con mayor peso en el parlamento y la
población lo señala como responsable de
la crisis que asola el país mi principal
reivindicación es que el grupo
abandona el parlamento ha reinado
durante diez años y no nos ha aportado
ninguna solución sin embargo el
presidente del parlamento y líder de
ennahda rached ghanouchi también lanzó
un llamado a sus seguidores a protestar
en contra de las decisiones del
presidente lo que el presidente ha
emprendido hoy no es menos que un golpe
de estado
ante una crisis con distintas caras
política económica y sanitaria no hay
respuestas a la pregunta sobre qué
implicaciones tendrá la decisión
presidencial en las instituciones en los
hospitales y en las calles